السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
[Silence]
الله
بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب العالمين والصلاه
والسلام على رسوله
الكريم واشهد ان لا اله الا الله وحده لا
شريك له واشهد ان محمدا عبده
ورسوله اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا
محمد وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين اما
بعد يقول الله
تعالى جنات عدن يدخلونها ومن صلح من
ابائهم وازواجهم
وذرياتهم
والملائكه يدخلون عليهم من كل
باب سلام عليكم بما صبرتم فنعم عقب
الدار هذا جزاء اولي
الالباب الذين سبق
ذكرهم في الايات
الماضيه الذين وصفهم الله تعالى
بالعلم وهو علم ينفع صاحبه
علم
شرعي قال افمن يعلم ان ما انزل اليك من
ربك الحق كمان هو اعمى انما يتذكر اولو
الالباب ثم ساق الله تعالى لهم صفات قال
الذين يوفون بعهد الله ولا ينقضون
الميثاق والذين يصلون ما امر الله به ان
يوصل ويخشون ربهم ويخافون سوء الحساب
والذين صبروا ابتغاء وجه ربهم واقاموا
الصلاه وانفقوا مما رزقناهم سرا
وعلانيه ويدرؤون بالحسنه السيئه اولئك لهم
عقب
الدار وعقب الدار بمعنى العاقبه المحموده
في
الاخره في دار
السلام ثم قال تع جنات
عدن جنات جمع جنه
والجنه
البستان لكنه البستان
الذي من كثافه
اشجاره الملتويه ومن
خضرته فهذا
البستان لا ترى الارض من تحت الاشجار من
كثافه الا
اشجار فان الارض متنه من
تحتها الجيم والنون في لغه العرب اذا
اجتمعت فانها تدل غالبا على الستر ستر
الشيء يقول جنين مثلا له مستور في بطن
الام او مثلا الجن لانهم مستورون عن عين
الناس عن عين بني ادم او
مثلا
الجنه او
مثلا الجنه او ما شابه ذلك او الجنون
مثلا
لانه يستر عقل
صاحبه ف الجنه في دلاله على الستر ستر
الارض من تحت هذه الاشجار
الكثيفه تتستر الارض فليست جنه وانما هي
جنات
عدن وعدن بمعنى
الخلود في لغه
العرب ومنه عدن في في في
اليمن قال لهذه المنطقه عدن وهي منطقه
بجانب
البحر لانها
ا يصلح فيها الزراعه طيله السنه
وخضارها خالد فيقال لها
عدن وهنا قوله تعالى جنات عدن يعني جنات
خلود يكون الانسان خالدا في هذه الجنات
هذه الجنات منصوف
بالخلود وهذا يدل على خلود صاحبها اصحابها
اذا كانت هذه الجنات خالده دون اصحابها
فلا فائده لنا بذكر خلود هذه الجنات فهي
جنات خالده بمعنى اصحابها
خالدون والله عز وجل يذكر هذا كثيرا في
القران يقول خالدين فيها
ابدا لان الخلود في القران على معنيين عند
العرب يقولون خالد
بمعنى ماكث مكثا
طويلا ويقولون خالد بمعنى المعنى الثاني
الذي هو الخلود
المؤبد لذلك العرب تسمي ابنائهم باسم خالد
تفاؤلا تفاؤلا بطول العمر ويقولون خالد
يقولون جبال خالده ليس معناها انها
خالده للابد وانما المقصود انها خالده
يعني لها نوع خلود مكث
طويل لذلك في
القران كلمه خالد او
خالدين فانها في الاصل بمعنى المكث
الطويل الاصل في القران المعنى الاصلي
الخلود المكث الطويل فاذا جاءت كلمه ابدا
فهذا يدل على المكث
المؤبد وهذا جاء في
اصحاب الجنه خالدين فيها ابدا في ايات عده
وجاء في اصحاب النار في ثلاث ايات خالدين
فيها ابدا سوره النساء سوره الاحزاب سوره
الجن وصف ف الله اهل النار بانهم خالدين
فيها
ابدا يقول جنات عدن
يدخلونها فاذا جاء الوصف للمكان بانه
خالد جنات عدن يعني
خالده
يدخلونها فمن باب اولى اصحابها خالدون
لانها اهبت لهم جنات عدن يدخلونها و من
صلح
يعني والذين صلحوا من ابائهم وازواجهم
وذرياتهم فذكر هنا الاصول الاباء
وازواجهم
وذرياتهم الفروع والثمار
والثمره
ف هؤلاء يدخلون الجنه معهم
تكرمه للصالح الاكبر في العائله
كلها يعني ينظر في سلاله الرجل اصلح واحد
في هذا هذه
السلاله مكانه في الجنه يكون مكان العائله
العائله كلها بشرط انه يكونوا مسلمين
اسلموا لانه لا يدخل الجنه كافر
فالاسلام شرط لدخول
الجنه وقد قال و معروف عند الصحابه
والتابعين ان مفتاح الجنه لا اله الا الله
مفتاح الجنه لا اله الا الله فالذي ليس له
هذا ليس له
مفتاح لا يفتح له
اصلا فهؤلاء
يدخلون قوله
تعالى
احسن ما كانوا
يعملون في بعض الايات الله سبحانه
وتعالى يذكر انه يجزي اصحاب الجنه باحسن
ما كانوا
يعملون وذريه
الشخص هذا من حسنات الشخص ايضا اليس كذلك
لانه من كسبه وان ليس للانسان الا ما سحى
من كسبه هذا من سع
اولاده
ف كذلك قه تعالى وكان ابوهما
صالح يعني حف
الابناء بسبب صلاح
الاباء على كل
حال قوله تعالى باحسن ما كانوا
يعملون يعني احسن من او ما كان من عمل جاء
من هذا العرق او
هذا او هذا النسب فان الله
تعالى يجزي
بقيه
اهل هذا
الاسم وهذا من كرم الله سبحانه
وتعالى فانه ينظر الى الاشخاص
فيجزي الانسان باحسن ما كان يعمل ينظر الى
احسن ما عمل ثم
يجزى الباقي على حسب ذلك وهذا يكون
معيار لدخول الجنه ثم ينظر في العائله
كذلك احسن ما في هذه العائله وينظر ايضا
في السلاله والقبيله وهلم
جره
ولذلك
خير
الانبياء محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم ومن
اكرامه ان جعل الله خير الامم امته خير
الكتب كتبه عليه الصلاه والسلام فقال صلى
الله عليه
وسلم نحن الاخرون الاولون يوم القيامه
الجنه لا تفتح لاحد سواه جاء في صحيح مسلم
حديث
انس ان الناس يقفون على ابواب الجنه واول
من يطرق الباب نبينا محمد صلى الله عليه
وسلم فيقال من فيقول محمد فيقول امرت الا
افتح لاحد سواك ثم يفتح له
الابواب فعلى كل حال قوله تعالى ومن صلح
الصلاح هنا بمعنى بالمعنى الشرعي الصلاح
يعني ان يصلح هذا
للجنه ان يكون صالحا للجنه ولا
يصلح احد ولا قلب ولا تصلح روح للجنه الا
اذا ان مزجت بلا اله الا
الله
ف من صلح من
ابائهم وذري وازواجهم وذرياتهم
والملائكه يدخلون عليهم من كل باب يهنون
يهنئونه يدخلون عليهم من كل باب ليس بس من
باب ابواب الجنه بل من ابواب
القصور التي هم فيها الملائكه تدخل عليهم
من الابواب جميعه اول ما يزف الى الجنه
واول ما يزف الى
قصره ف الملائكه تاتيه تهنيه ويدخلون
عليهم من كل باب ما هي تهنئتهم سلام عليكم
بما
صبرتم فنعم عقب
الدار وقد جاء في هذه الايه
روايه اخرجها الامام احمد في مسنده
والطبراني في معجمه والطبري في
تفسيره ان النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم قال
لاصحابه و هوو حديث
صحيح
يقول اتدرون اول من يدخل
الجنه قال والله والرسول اعلم قال فان اول
من يدخل
الجنه المهاجرون
الفقراء
الذين تتقى بهم
المكاره
وتسد بهم الثغور ويموت احدهم وحاجته في
صدره لا يجد لها
قضاء انظروا الى هذه الاوصاف اول من يدخل
الجنه
من المهاجرون
الفقراء الذين تركوا كل
شيء ولم ياخذوا
شيئا من اجرهم في الدنيا المهاجر من
نهى الله عنه طبعا المهاجرون في زمن النبي
صلى الله عليه وسلم والمهاجر من بلد الكفر
الى بلد الايمان من باب او يدخلون في هذا
المعنى ف المهاجرون
الفقراء هم هجروا كل شيء نهى الله عنه من
بلاد وعباد واعمال
واحوال
وصفات
ثم لم ياخذوا على ذلك شيئا من الاجر في
الدنيا لا غنوا من وراها العمليه ولا
ارتاحوا من ورا
العمليه النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم يقول
الفقراء
المهاجرون الذين تتقى بهم
المكاره الشيء الذي يكرهه الاغنياء ودوا
فلان
ما ما يحب حدا يعمل هذه الاشياء سواء في
الحرب او في غير الحرب في الحراسه وفي
التنظيف وفي الاشياء اللي الاغنياء
يتكبرون عنها فلان مع انه هذا
مهاجري هذا صاحب تقوى مدفوع بالابواب قد
يكون لو اقسم على الله
لابره ويراه الناس ويعتدون عليه لماذا
لانه ما له منزله رفيعه بين عامه الناس
الناس ينظرون الى السلطان الظاهر الدنيوي
ينظرون الى يغترون
بالمناظر يغترون باصحاب
الاموال والعجيب الذين يتملقون لاصحاب
الاموال هم اصلا مش رايحين يستفيدوا من
هذا التملك كله بس يتمسح
فيه لكن
هذا
الكل هذا ما حد فطن له يقول الذين تتقى
بهم المكاره وتسد بهم
الثغور ثغور ثغور اللي في الحرب في الحدود
في مكان خطير جدا على الجنود الصف الاول
اول ما يدخلوا ويذوق اشد باس العدو حط
الفقراء هذول الاغنياء بيكونوا
ورا هذول يعني بعد ما تنتهي المعركه بيجي
الاغنياء بلفوا كان يقول الزلمه انه كان
في المعركه لكن هذول اللي في
الامام وعلى الثغور هذول ما حد فطن لهم
اصلا
يقول المهاجرون الفقراء الذين تتقى بهم
المكاره وتسد بهم الثغور ويموت احده
وحاجته في
صدره لا يستطيع لها
قضاء يتوسط لها الولد مثلا ابنه توسط
لبنته مش عارف المسكين لو حاجه وفي بعض
الروايات له
حاجه له حاجته الى ذي سلطان لا يستطيع لها
قضاء في بعض روايات هذه
الروايه
يقال فيدخلون الجنه فيقول الله تعالى
لملائكته
اذهبوا الى
اولئك
فحيو فتقول
الملائكه ربنا
نحن
نحن كما في الحديث سكان
سمائك يعني يسكنون ويعيشون ويستوطن
السماء وهذا اشرف من
الارض
ويقولون نحن اهل
سمائك
وخيرتك من خلقك اف تمرنا ان ناتم فنسل
عليهم
قال
فياتون فيدخلون عليهم من كل باب سلام
عليكم بما صبرتم فنعم عقب
الدار
ف يقول تعالى سلام عليكم بما
صبرتم وسلام هنا من
السلامه لكن هذا هو ايش هذا المصدر المصدر
سلام يعني ليس فقط عليهم سلامه بل سلام
عليهم يقولون الملائكه تقول سلام عليكم ب
الباء هنا السببيه يعني
بسبب ما صبرتم يعني ب بسبب
صبركم صبروا على طاعه الله صبروا عن معصيه
الله صبروا على اقدار
الله ليس فقط اقدار الله المؤلمه بل ايضا
على اقدار
الله
المفرحه لانه ما بطلوا اكثر الناس نا
قد قد يصبر
نفسه اذا كان في مجتمع مسلم على
المصيبه لان الناس يتوقعون منه ذلك لكن
اذا انفرجت الدنيا
امامه واغناه الله عن
الناس
و اعطاه
الصحه والسعه سعه العيش اكثر الناس ينام
يغفل
حينئذ يغفل عن ذكر الله يغفل عن عباده
الله عن طاعه
الله
و بيعطي لله شويه مصاري كل سنه او كل شهر
و بصليها الصلاه وبس اجتهاده في طاعه الله
ومراقب قبته لله تصبح من
العادات يعني عباداته تصير من العادات في
غفله نسال الله
العافيه فهذا
ايضا ليس من الصبر ما صبر الذي
يصبر وقت ما ينام الناس ويغفل الناس
يكون لاجا بذكر الله
ووقت
ما يجزع
الناس يكون
صابرا ووقت ما يخاف الناس يكون امنا ووقت
ما يكون الناس في امان او يشعرون بالامان
يكون خائف من الله سبحانه وتعالى هكذا
صاحب القران هكذا من له
هذا هذه الدار يقول سلام عليكم بما صبرتم
فنعم عقب
الدار نعم عقب الدار نكتفي بهذا القدر
والله اعلم وصلى الله وسلم على نبينا محمد
وعلى اله واصحابه
اجمعين number 22
2ر سه
الر الله سبحانه
وتالى يست الله سبحانه
وتعالى home the event home event
home the home event the home
pe
peace
‏this is a reference to
paradise
and these people that
are enter paradise at this time
have trait الله سبحانه
وتالى vers all about that but the their
tra ‏tra which all other traits
followed was that know that what has
come to the prophet عليه وسلم from his
lord is the tru they know that knowledge
in قران
articat articulate
certain and so because of this
certain the best
of they the best of character they the
best of
‏traits and they
were considered by سبحانه وتعالى of
انت الله سبحانه
وتعالى regarding these people of
intellect he describes them to
us with a few
descriptions these descriptions
being they are the ones who
‏ff the cen
of and they do not
on and
those ties and
ff
that andar lord
andur
are
of
‏and those who are
patient and they are patient for the
sake and for the pleasure of
lord and est
pr and
give from that we have given them and
bless them with public and
priv
الله سبحانه
وتالى
etern which they will be permitted
enter they and whoever
is
acit
par
‏par spouses or their
offspring and the angels will come to
them from
every conat
them here الله سبحانه
وتالى they willer
parad
and those who ‏are fit from amongst
their from amongst their forefathers or
amongst their parents those who are fit
from amongst their
spouses those who are fit from amongst
their children or their offspring their
children their children's children
etc
now what's meant here by fit being fit
to enter paradise
م
in
الله
wor and follow the messenger
of
محد صل الله عليه
وسلم
محد and
so in order for a person to be for
paradise الله
محد
الله so
‏this is what makes a person fit for
paradise and so the
best from
among a family oran or
tri they will be placed in a level in
paradise
and everyone else aff with have any ti
with them they will be
‏h for the
original earner of that level he says
and the angels will ent to congratulate
them from
every door from every door of paradise
from of paradise from of their
pales
‏congratulations and their salutations
will be سلام علكم
بما meaning peace be upon you here in
this parad you will be in a state of
peace you will be in a state of health
you will be in state of
eternal
comfor and that is because of your
patience the more
‏person that doesn't get upset easy
that's one type of patience not all of
pati patience is much more
bro
قران
‏decree things pa upon pa ining from
disobedience patience in uring the
decree
ofy
here
theate
‏propelling
force for them to earn these great gens
in parad الله سبحانه
وتعالى this is the
best and the point here is it is the
best of abod it is the best of hes is
the best
ofs is the best ofs
‏that any human being can have the
pinnacle of human
poal والله اعلم وصلى الله وسلم على نبينا
محمد وعلى اله واصحابه
اجمعين
[Silence]
م